the brain is a noisy place neurons
chatter constantly sending messages that
underlie our thoughts feelings emotions
and just about everything we do now a
new view of the synapse the place where
two nerve cells or neurons meet offers a
detailed look at how neurons send
messages using a variety of techniques
scientists reconstructed a rat synaptic
boot on the message sending tip of a
neuron the scientists made each protein
in their reconstruction a different
color so they could see where the
proteins are in the bouton and how they
interact despite what it looks like
these proteins only fill about 7% of the
space inside a bhutan still it can get
quite crowded which makes it hard for
the small spheres called vesicles to
move around vesicles are the ferries
that shuttle proteins and chemical
messages to the edge of the bouton and
release them into the sinners a single
vesicle is about 42 nanometers in
diameter the tiny sphere is loaded with
proteins on its outer shell and the
chemical messages are packed inside the
mission of the vesicle is to move these
messages to the Bouton's active zone the
active zone shown in glowing red houses
specialized proteins to help vesicles
release their payloads which are
responsible for cell to cell
communication once the vesicles make it
to the active zone they meld with the
cell membrane and release their messages
into the synapse of course this is only
the tip of a neuron the team is planning
to recreate an entire neuron to
understand in extreme detail the
potentially billions of transactions
neurons make every second and how those
communications make the brain work